رفيقه جديده من وثائق البانتاجون المسربه
حصلت عليها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وتتحدث عن
اربعه سيناريوهات غير متوقعه للحرب بين
روسيا واوكرانيا اضافه الى تاثيرها على
مجريات المعارك وكالات الاستخبارات وضعت
هذه الافتراضات لمساعده العسكريين او
السياسيين على حد سواء على التفكير في
النتائج المحتمله اثناء تقييمهم لخياراتهم
تاريخ الوثيقه يعود الى الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير ويحمل علامه سنه واحده مما يدل
على ان التحليل جرى بعد عام من بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا
السيناريوهات الافتراضيه للحرب في
اوكرانيا تشمل مقتل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ومقتل الرئيس الاوكراني
تغيير القياده في الجيش الروسي واخيرا
حدود ضربات اوكرانيه على الكرملين الوثيقه
بحثت ما يمكن ان يحدث اذا ضربت اوكرانيا
والتصعيد الذي قد يليه خاصه وان وان حدثت
او خاصه ان حدثت احتجاجات شعبيه تطالب
الرئيس الروسي بالرد الرد بحسب الوثيقه قد
يكون من خلال اطلاق تعبئه عسكريه جديده
واسعه النطاق والنظر في استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه او ربما قد يدفع الرئيس
الروسي للتفاوض على تسويه للحرب اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عبرت اكثر من
مره عن قلقها من توجيه ضربه كبيره لروسيا
من قبل اوكرانيا خشيه حدود تصعيد من
الجانب الروسي بطبيعه الحال ومخاطر مثل
هذا الهجوم من الجانب الاوكراني احد
الاسباب التي جعلت الولايات المتحده
متردده في تزويد كياف بصواريخ بعيده المدى
وافقا لنيويورك تايمز لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوث
ائقيه الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات